Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Dana, Tomás, Rachel, Naomi, James. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
We ran the team-assess tool on everything from Q2 — transcripts, chat, PRs, retros, the pulse survey. Overall health came back 2.7 out of 5. I want to be clear this isn't a gotcha; it's a mirror.
Our three lowest dimensions are trust, conflict, and commitment, all at 2.5. The report gives five recommendations. Let's put a name on each one, because a recommendation nobody owns is just a nice sentence.
I'll own the conflict recommendation, because it's squarely about how I run meetings. The report literally cites me holding 56 to 66 percent of the airtime.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Just flagging that this touches the CARE governance framework, so loop me in when it firms up.
Round-robin, async pre-reads, and I'll let the insights tool nudge me when I pass 40 percent.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Let's confirm in the channel.
Yeah.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
I'll take the trust one with Sarah — blameless incident notes and celebrating pulling the cord early.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
And the accountability recommendation is partly mine to fix: I'm the security single point of failure, so I'll onboard a second reviewer this quarter.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Yeah, exactly.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to community review and the advisory process anyway.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Good point — let's do that.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the manifest schema and validator anyway.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Yeah, exactly.
Sure, I can own that.
I'll pair on trust, and I'll own commitment — the written reopening bar so a settled decision like the license question stops coming back three times.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Agreed, let's capture it.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the access needs-board and credits broker anyway.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the access needs-board and credits broker.
Right, that's what I meant.
Okay, next thing on the agenda.
Let me share my screen so we're all looking at the same thing.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the CARE governance framework.
Sure, I can own that.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Agreed, let's capture it.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the CARE governance framework.
Just flagging that this touches the security review pipeline, so loop me in when it firms up.
Good point — let's do that.
Makes sense to me.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Sure, I can own that.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Sure, I can own that.
Agreed, let's capture it.
Good point — let's do that.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Yeah, exactly.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Sure, I can own that.
Dana and I will take results — outcome over optics. Q4 fundraiser is coming and that's exactly when the optics pressure spikes, so we'll watch each other on it.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync anyway.
Yeah, exactly.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Yeah, exactly.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Okay, works for me.
Mm-hm.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Okay, works for me.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the security review pipeline.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Makes sense to me.
How does this interact with community review and the advisory process, if at all?
That's fair.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
On the conflict one — I want the format to include async pre-reads, not just round-robin.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Agreed, let's capture it.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Sure, I can own that.
I contribute better having read ahead, and the report flagged that I was scored near zero in meetings while being the top chat contributor. I'll help design the format.
Just flagging that this touches the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, so loop me in when it firms up.
Yeah, exactly.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Let's confirm in the channel.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Right.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Sure, I can own that.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
That's fair.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Just flagging that this touches the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, so loop me in when it firms up.
Good point — let's do that.
Right, that's what I meant.
One caution before we run off and implement. Let's make sure we're changing behavior, not gaming a number. The report is a mirror, not the goal. If we optimize the score we've missed the point.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the CARE governance framework.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Sure, I can own that.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to community review and the advisory process anyway.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Okay, works for me.
Okay.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Yeah, exactly.
Agreed, and that's the frame I want to keep. Owners are assigned. We run a fresh assessment at the end of Q3 and see whether the behaviors actually moved.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Let's confirm in the channel.
Exactly.
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
One thing: how does this affect the community review and the advisory process timeline?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Question before we wrap — does any of this change what I'm doing on the access needs-board and credits broker?
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Sarah has the follow-up on the CARE governance framework — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Dana has the follow-up on the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Tomás has the follow-up on the security review pipeline — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.